* Anschwellende,
spannungsvolle Klänge *
Mireya
steht vor einer Lebertransplantation.
(Mann) Schau,
ich glaube, sie sind schon bereit.
(Ärztin) Hallo!
- Wir sind die Ärzte.
(Alle) Hallo.
Wir würden diese Medikamente
durch die Vene geben.
Ein Eingriff,
der ihr Leben retten soll.
Wir machen langsam, kein Problem.
So.
Ich glaube, sie ist schon weg.
Ja, sie ist schon weg.
- Tschüss, Mireya.
Mach's gut.
Sie merkt nichts mehr. Tschau!
Mach's gut, gell? Ist gut?
Alles gut bei dir?
* Leise Klänge *
Sie sind krank
und wollen nichts als leben.
Sie warten auf ein Organ,
das ein Verstorbener spendet.
Ein Leben geht zu Ende.
Eines wird verlängert.
Die Organtransplantation
ist ein Eingriff, der bewegt.
Es geht um Ethik, Glaube,
Gesetz und Moral.
Um grosses Glück ...
Ich freue mich wie verrückt auf den
nächsten Abschnitt in meinem Leben.
Und ich bin sehr dankbar,
das alles erleben zu dürfen.
... und um Ängste.
Was heisst die Transplantation
für die Empfängerinnen und Empfänger?
Wie genau läuft sie ab?
Wir hatten den Schnitt
um ca. 20.20 Uhr.
Und die Leber ist sehr schön.
Es braucht wahnsinnig Geduld.
Wie ist die Lebensqualität
nach dem grossen Eingriff?
Es geht um Warten ...
... Hoffnung ...
... und vielleicht Erlösung.
(Frau) Zeig mal,
was die Puppe drin hat.
Er hat hier drin ...
... so einen Reissverschluss
am Bauch.
Das ist der Darm.
Herz, Lunge.
Leber.
Wo ist die Niere?
Ah, das ist die Niere.
Und das? Leber?
- Leber.
Das Leben der Familie Rast dreht sich
um die Krankheit der Tochter.
Meine.
Wenn ein Kind stirbt ...
... kriege ich dessen Leber.
Dann rufen Sie uns an. He!
Sie rufen uns an.
Und dann muss ich sofort in Genf ...
In Genf befindet sich
das Leberzentrum für Kinder.
... operiert werden.
Das einzige in der Schweiz.
Mireya leidet unter einer
extrem seltenen Genkrankheit.
Weltweit sind nur
in paar wenige Fälle bekannt.
Zurzeit geht es ihr gut.
Sie besucht die Schule.
Was machst du wieder, Rocco? Na?
- Ja.
Noch fünf, oder?
(Leise) 80 ...
Wie viel?
- 80.
Ein für andere Kinder harmloser
Infekt aber, Husten oder Schnupfen,
kann für sie lebensgefährlich werden.
Fünf.
Wie viel?
- 50.
Und wo ist die 50?
- Hier.
Gut.
Die Eltern sind in ständiger Sorge.
Das hat man immer im Kopf,
egal, was man macht.
Ob beim Arbeiten, beim Fernsehen
oder wenn man weggeht.
Das beschäftigt einen, und das ...
Wie soll ich sagen? Das bleibt drin.
Das kann man nicht ausschalten.
Auch nach der Transplantation
ist es ein Teil unseres Lebens.
Kann man nicht ausschalten.
Schon zweimal erkrankte Mireya
schwer. Sie hatte hohes Fieber.
Die Leber versagte. Seither
hat ihre Mutter keine Ruhe mehr.
In den ersten paar Wochen,
als sie wieder zur Schule ging,
habe ich ...
Weisst du noch?
Ich ging immer in der Pause und
kontrollierte, ob sie Fieber hat.
Stimmt.
- Ja, und ...
Dafür konnte ich drinnen ...
Für sie war es schon peinlich,
dass ich ging.
Aber mir ist das Wichtigste,
dass sie ... - ... gesund bleibe.
Bald wird Mireya
auf die sog. Dringlichkeitsliste
für die Lebertransplantation gesetzt.
Die Zeit drängt.
Zu gross ist die Gefahr, dass sie
jetzt, im Winter, wieder erkrankt.
Diese Seite ist gut.
Die Koffer sind gepackt.
Das müssen wir bereit haben für ...
Wenn das Telefon klingelt.
Dann müssen wir schnell ...
schnell gehen.
Alle Ärzte haben gesagt,
ich müsse bereit sein
und die Koffer gepackt haben.
Ich bin bereit.
Ich möchte meine neue Leber haben!
Aua.
* Die Mutter ächzt, Mireya lacht. *
Schaffst du's?
- Nein, sie ist schwer!
Und jetzt?
- Ich bin ...
Rocco will natürlich auch noch,
schau! - Nein!
Doch, komm, Rocco!
- Nein.
5 Min. heisst eine halbe Stunde.
Nein, Nein.
Anita Laurent
hat am Universitätsspital Zürich
schon zwei Transplantationen erlebt.
Hier haben wir
viele Stunden gewartet.
Ja.
- Viele Stunden.
Da hinten
hängt eine Platte von der Decke.
Die will ich immer noch ...
- Die ist sicher noch so.
Seit dreieinhalb Jahren
ist die nicht richtig montiert.
Und jedes Mal sagt er, nächstes Mal
montiere er sie richtig.
Ich nehme eine Bockleiter mit.
Die hängt vermutlich immer noch.
- Vermutlich.
So viele Stunden haben wir gewartet,
dass wir diese Bilder
nicht mehr sehen können,
die Decke nicht mehr sehen können.
Anita Laurent litt unter Leberkrebs.
Ihr Mann
entschied sich vor zwei Jahren,
ihr einen Teil seiner Leber
zu spenden.
Die Leber ist neben der Niere
das einzige Organ,
das für eine Lebendspende
in Betracht kommt.
* Anita atmet tief. *
Jetzt kämpfen wir
schon seit zwei Jahren.
Und ...
Das war eine Option.
Für unsere Kinder haben wir
versprochen, dass wir alles machen.
Dass ...
Alles, was wir machen können.
Schon jetzt aber, ein paar Tage
nach der Transplantation, ist klar:
Tschüss.
Anita Laurent muss in Kürze
nochmals operiert werden.
In ihrer Leber
ist ein Gefäss verstopft - Thrombose.
Eine gefürchtete Komplikation.
Ehemann Alfred verabschiedet sich.
* Romanisch *
Meine grösste Angst vor der Ope-
ration: dass ich nicht spenden kann.
Und nach der Operation,
dass sie ans Bett kommen und sagen,
meine Frau sei gestorben oder so.
Und ich hätte es nicht mitgekriegt.
(Leise) Ja, das war hart.
Aber sonst hatte ich keine Angst.
Um mich nicht.
Um meine Frau hatte ich viel Angst.
Grüezi miteinander.
- (Beide) Grüezi.
Heute fährt die 40-Jährige
noch alle drei Monate
vom Unterengadin
zur Kontrolle nach Zürich.
Wir würden noch eine Blutentnahme
machen, Blutdruck und Puls messen.
Was machen Sie am Wochenende?
Gehen Sie noch weg?
Skifahren. Also ich natürlich nicht.
- Wenn schönes Wetter ist.
Also ich. Sie fährt noch nicht Ski.
- Nein, ich nicht.
Geht es?
- Mhm.
Die Werte sind gut in jüngster Zeit.
So.
Anita Laurent erholt sich.
Zum ersten Mal
seit dem stationären Aufenthalt
gehen sie
zurück auf die Intensivstation,
wo Anita Laurent
um ihr Leben kämpfte.
(Beide) Grüezi.
- Grüezi miteinander.
Ella enconuschel jeu,
quella cun las ...
(Beide) Grüezi, Herr Schüpbach.
- Grüezi. Sie sehen blendend aus.
Danke, es geht mir auch besser.
- Schön.
Keine Dialyse mehr.
- Das habe ich gelesen.
Gestern habe ich in Chur
den Katheder entfernt.
Ja, es läuft langsam wieder.
- Schön.
Sie waren schon mal kritisch dran.
Man ...
... wusste nicht, wo es durchgeht.
- Genau.
Ich schon!
- Das ist gut.
Ich hatte nie das Gefühl,
es sei so ...
Ich war immer optimistisch, wirk-
lich, und habe auch immer gekämpft.
Ich weiss noch,
als ich mal nach der OP rauf kam.
Ich glaube, der Schwiegervater
brachte mich mit dem Rollstuhl.
Ich sah ihr in die Augen und dachte:
"Jetzt stirbt sie. Jetzt ..."
Da habe ich das erste Mal ...
ein wenig die Hoffnung verloren.
Ich hatte wirklich Angst,
dass sie stirbt.
Obwohl die Gefässverstopfung
rasch behoben wird,
erholt sich Anita Laurent nicht.
Zwei Monate nach der Transplantation
wird klar:
Die Thrombose
hat nachhaltigen Schaden angerichtet.
Es braucht wahnsinnig Geduld.
Ja.
* Sanfte, blecherne Klänge *
In der Schweiz warten
rund 200 Menschen auf eine Leber.
Insgesamt
fehlen mehr als 1'400 Organe.
Jedes Jahr sterben Dutzende von Men-
schen, die auf der Warteliste sind.
Nur wenige Schweizerinnen
und Schweizer halten fest,
ob sie ihre Organe spenden wollen
oder nicht.
Kein Mensch befasst sich gerne
mit der eigenen Endlichkeit.
Vier Monate nach der Transplantation
ist Anita Laurent
immer noch im Spital.
Mittlerweile ist klar:
Die Spenderleber ihres Mannes
ist nicht zu retten.
Jetzt bin ich auf der Warteliste
für die Transplantation.
Weil es mit dieser
nicht funktioniert hat.
Und ... ich warte.
Ja, weil es ist einfach ...
So kann ich nicht leben.
Es ist schade,
dass es diese Komplikationen gab.
Aber es ermöglicht jetzt ...
Es ... Eine Tür schliesst sich,
eine andere öffnet sich.
Jetzt hat sie die Möglichkeit,
eine neue Leber zu kriegen.
Zwar dieses Mal von einem Totspen-
der, aber dafür eine ganze Leber.
Und ich bin froh, dass ...
sie diese Chance kriegt.
Weitere drei Monate
muss Anita Laurent noch durchhalten.
Dann wird ihr zum zweiten Mal
eine Leber transplantiert -
ohne Komplikationen.
Das war vor eineinhalb Jahren.
Es ist schön,
dass ich wieder gehen kann.
Auf den eigenen Beinen.
- Auf den eigenen Beinen rauslaufen.
Aber man fühlt
mit den Menschen hinter dem Vorhang.
Denkt an sie. - Das ist
natürlich ganz anders als ...
Man weiss, was hinten
vielleicht ungefähr läuft.
Gut. Adieu, vielen Dank.
- Adieu miteinander.
* Vereinzelte
leise E-Gitarren-Klänge *
Ein Quartier
am Rande von Emmenbrücke.
Katja Rast
ist nur noch für ihre Tochter da.
Ihre Arbeit im Restaurant
einer Autobahnraststätte
musste sie aufgeben.
Der erste Zusammenbruch der Tochter
ereignete sich vor sechs Jahren
in Katjas Heimat, in Bulgarien.
Der zweite in der Schweiz.
Das ist in Bulgarien.
Da war sie dort.
Das ist auch von dort.
Sie hatte nur Medikamente.
* Vereinzelte
leise E-Gitarren-Klänge *
Ende 2016
wiederholte sich der Albtraum.
Am Universitätsspital in Genf
erklärten die Ärzte,
dass Mireya
wohl nicht überleben werde.
* Sanfte, nachdenkliche Klänge *
Ich habe einfach nicht geglaubt,
dass sie sterben wird.
Ja.
Du bist in einem Loch.
Wie wenn dein Leben fertig wäre.
Denn wenn so etwas passiert ...
Ich dachte:
"Dann ist mein Leben auch fertig."
Dann will ich auch nicht ...
... nicht mehr Leben.
Denn für mich ist das alles.
* Leise, nachdenkliche Klänge *
So.
- Komm, wir machen das so.
Mireyas Freundinnen
kennen die Krankheitsgeschichte
und waren im Spital zu Besuch.
* Sie reden durcheinander. *
Das ist das Krankenhaus,
ist das gut für euch?
Die Erinnerungen an
die schwierige Zeit sind immer da.
Ich hatte überall Schläuche.
Überall.
Die hier sieht man auch noch,
hier am Hals irgendwo.
Und hier in der Nase hatte ich einen
und noch hier im Mund,
und hier noch zwei,
und hier noch einen,
eine Infusion im Fuss
und hier neun Infusionen.
Katheter auch noch.
Ich konnte gar nicht sprechen.
Das Essen habe ich
über die Schläuche bekommen.
Mein Körper
hat gar nicht gearbeitet, nichts.
Das war nicht so gut.
Mhm. Sie konnte nicht spielen.
* Die Freundin singt. *
Nein, tu es hier hin!
Martin Rast
ist selbständiger Landschaftsgärtner.
So ist er jederzeit abkömmlich,
wenn Mireya ihn braucht.
Für ihn ist klar,
dass er nach einer Transplantation
bei seiner Tochter
im Spital bleiben wird.
Obwohl er gerne arbeitet.
Ich bin eh der Typ,
der immer ... etwas machen muss.
Sonst studiere ich ...
... Dingen nach.
Und das kommt nicht so gut.
Irgendwann fange ich an zu drehen.
Bei mir muss immer etwas laufen.
Ich lasse es nicht so an mich ran.
Weil sonst ... Ja.
Ist nicht gut.
Darum lieber verdrängen.
Das klingt blöd, aber ...
Etwas verdrängen, kann man sagen.
Ablenken.
Und dann ...
... geht es mir gut.
Es bringt nichts, wenn zwei hypern.
Er weiss, dass seine Frau
wegen Mireya schlaflose Nächte hat.
Sie lässt das näher an sich ran
als ich.
Aber das ist ja normal als Mutter.
Dass man das ...
Dass das näher geht ...
als Mutter als als Vater.
Oder sagen wir es so:
Jemand muss ja ... stärker sein.
Er denkt immer, dass er das macht
wie ein richtiger ...
... Macho, müssen wir sagen.
Dass er stark ist und ...
Ja.
Aber ich sehe schon,
dass er auch Angst hat.
* Die Mädchen lachen. *
Was lacht ihr?
- Ist es lustig?
(Gespielt) Lacht nicht!
Wer noch einmal lacht ...
* Die Mädchen lachen. *
Für einmal
bleibt Hund Rocco aussen vor.
Schau! Ich wollte so machen.
Suppe.
- Suppe.
Bald wird Mireya auf die
dringliche Warteliste gesetzt.
Guten Appetit.
- Guten Appetit.
Dann kann alles schnell gehen.
Inselspital Bern,
eines von sechs Transplantations-
zentren in der Schweiz.
Hier werden
Herzen und Lebern transplantiert.
Vanessa Banz ist leitende Ärztin.
Das Spezialgebiet der Chirurgin ist,
salopp gesagt, der Bauchraum.
Sie ist Viszeral-
und Transplantationsmedizinerin.
Heute steht an,
dass wir
mit einem Patienten sprechen,
der seit gut einer Woche
bei uns ist.
Er ist aktiv auf der Warteliste,
wartet auf ein Organ.
Und hat sich
sehr rasch verschlechtert,
wahrscheinlich
aufgrund eines Infekts.
Er hat viel Wasser im Bauch,
das Zeichen eines Endstadiums
einer Lebererkankung.
Letzte Nacht haben wir
ein Angebot für ihn erhalten,
und im Idealfall
wird er heute transplantiert,
was uns natürlich wahnsinnig freut.
Morgen, Morgen.
Guten Morgen, Herr Cart.
* Unverständlich *
Genau, warmes Herz, kalte Hände,
immer noch.
Wie geht es Ihnen heute Morgen?
Logischerweise
natürlich voller Hoffnung.
Nein,
eigentlich ist es keine Hoffnung,
sondern die Bestätigung dessen,
was Sie mir geschenkt haben,
und zu wissen: Es klappt.
Ich bin noch nicht auf der Liste
für das letzte Frühstück da oben.
Wie war Ihre Nacht?
Panikattacken.
Ich wusste nicht, wo ich bin.
Ich brauchte eine Weile,
bis ich es wieder wusste.
"Was spinnst du überhaupt
durch die Gegend?"
Aber jetzt haben Sie das Gefühl,
Sie sind wieder voll da? - Ja.
Wie ist es, wenn ich hier drücke?
- Ich merke es kaum.
Wir hatten geplant,
heute Wasser abzulassen,
aber das machen wir nicht jetzt,
das ist nicht sinnvoll.
Wenn es offen ist, können Sie den
Sauger nehmen und leeren. - Genau.
Ja. Also, der Infekt
ist jetzt klar kontrolliert.
Man muss sicher weiterfahren
mit den Antibiotika,
allenfalls noch etwas zusätzlich
um die Transplantation rum,
weil wir ja am Anfang
so starke Medikamente geben
gegen die Abstossung. Nicht,
dass der Infekt schlimmer wird.
Der Ablauf: Sobald wir hören,
dass es okay ist mit der Leber ...
Rufe ich meine Frau an.
Das ist ganz wichtig - nicht,
dass die aus allen Wolken fällt,
wenn man sie
nach der Operation anruft.
Dann kann man Ihnen
auch ungefähr sagen, um welche Zeit.
Zuerst sind Sie wie besprochen
auf der Intensivstation,
und danach nicht mehr in diesem
Zimmer. Sie werden im H Nord sein.
Im Bereich,
wo alle Frischtransplantierten sind.
Wieder in der 23, wie das erste Mal.
- Genau. Ungefähr dort.
Wo man die Berge wirklich sieht.
- Ja, dort sieht man sie besser.
Nicht nur die Baustelle. - Die
hört man leider auch in der 23.
Die braucht es auch,
das ist wichtig. - Okay.
Rene Cart ist 63.
In zwölf Monaten
hat er 50 kg verloren.
Sein Zustand
hat sich rapide verschlechtert.
Jetzt sieht er Licht
am Ende des Tunnels.
Ich glaube, ich sehe Zukunftssachen,
die ich mit meiner Frau noch plane,
die endlich in Erfüllung ...
Die wir anpacken können.
(Mit erstickter Stimme)
Ich freue mich einfach wahnsinnig.
Das ist logisch.
Es ist ein Geschenk.
Entschuldigung.
Aber es ist wirklich ein Geschenk,
und ich freue mich unheimlich.
* Leise, melancholische Klänge *
Es nimmt einen schon mit.
Es sind ja nicht nur ...
Als Chirurg operiert man zwar -
das ist sehr technisch, manuell.
Man nimmt etwas raus,
ersetzt es mit etwas.
Aber weil es Patienten sind,
die lange auf der Warteliste sind,
die man immer wieder sieht,
die z.T. wieder ins Spital kommen,
weil sie wieder kranker sind,
baut man eine enge Beziehung
mit ihnen und der Familie auf.
Rene Cart
hat einen holprigen Weg vor sich.
Bei seiner Krankheit spielte
früher auch Alkohol eine Rolle.
Haben Suchtkranke
ein Anrecht auf ein Organ?
Diese Frage ist heftig umstritten.
Das Gesetz sagt:
Ja, unter gewissen Voraussetzungen.
Verantwortlich für die Organzuteilung
ist die Stiftung Swisstransplant,
im Auftrag des Bundes.
Das Computersystem errechnet,
wer ein Organ am dringlichsten
braucht, ohne Wertung.
Es kann sein, dass einzelne Patien-
ten nicht auf die Warteliste kommen.
Oder es bei einigen Suchtkrankheiten
gewisse Anforderungen gibt.
"Ich nehme jemanden
nur auf die Lungenwarteliste,
wenn er nicht mehr raucht."
Das ist bei der Lunge so angedacht.
Bei der Leber dasselbe -
man ist der Meinung:
Kommt jemand auf die Leberwarte-
liste, sollte er nicht mehr trinken.
Jeder von uns
hat mal Fehler gemacht.
Wenn man diese Fehler erkennt,
dazu steht und sagen kann:
"So, fertig, jetzt ist es anders."
"Jetzt kehre ich mein Leben um.
Ich trinke nicht mehr, Punkt."
"Ich habe Drogen genommen -
ich mache das nicht mehr."
"Ich habe Hepatitis C erwischt,
aber jetzt ist fertig."
Dann habe ich sehr Mühe
mit der Einstellung ...
... von Leuten, die sagen:
"Der hat ja früher das gemacht."
"Der darf nie ... Der hat kein Recht
auf etwas Besseres."
* Vogelgezwitscher *
Ramosch im Unterengadin.
Anita Laurent
ist endlich zurück bei ihrer Familie.
* Sie sprechen romanisch. *
Es war lange anders.
Ja.
V.a. unmittelbar nach der Operation
war es streng.
Die Kinder
mussten Verantwortung übernehmen.
Eigentlich noch normal.
Nur ein bisschen Haushalt und so.
Aber das war ganz okay, ja.
Ich glaube,
sie kennen gar nichts anderes.
Ja.
- Ja.
Bei uns ist es halt schon so lange
so. Es sind jetzt fast vier Jahre.
Aber ich schaue schon,
dass sie, wenn es mir gut geht,
nicht zu viel
oder mal gar nicht helfen müssen.
Nur langsam
kam Anita Laurent zu Kräften.
* Sie spricht romanisch. *
Erst jetzt kann die Familie
das Geschehene aufarbeiten.
Die Eltern mit Sohn Aurelio
und den 13-jährigen Zwillingsmädchen.
* Sie sprechen romanisch. *
Ich hatte eine schlechte Prognose
vom Krebs auf der Leber,
der immer am gleichen Ort
wieder gewachsen ist.
Die einzige Möglichkeit: ein Stück
Leber von jemandem zu bekommen.
Mein Mann sagte sofort:
"Wir haben die gleiche Blutgruppe,
ich mache das."
Ich wusste, das würde nicht einfach.
Und auch die Ärzte sagten,
es würde schwierig werden.
Aber ich habe meinen Kindern
versprochen, alles zu probieren.
Aber wir sagten ihnen nie: "Ich gehe
jetzt die Leber transplantieren
und bin dann wieder gesund."
- Nein.
* Sie sprechen romanisch. *
Die Nachricht, dass der Vater
einen Teil seiner Leber spenden will,
hat die Kinder erschreckt.
Zuerst war ich nicht so begeistert
und sagte Nein.
Es gab halt das Risiko,
beide Eltern zu verlieren.
Jener Tag war ... ganz schlimm.
Wir sagten,
dass wir das machen wollen.
Dann hat sie gesagt,
das wolle sie nicht.
Würden beide sterben,
wären sie allein.
Dann gingen wir wieder nach Zürich
und hatten wieder Besprechungen.
Der Professor kam rein
und ich sagte,
ich müsse meiner Tochter
etwas erklären.
Er sagte: "Dann geh rauf
und sag deinen Kindern,
die Wahrscheinlichkeit,
dass sie überfahren werden,
ist grösser als dass du
nicht zurückkommst von der OP."
Ich habe ihr das gesagt, und
dann war sie sofort einverstanden.
Ja, dann ... Wenn der das sagt.
Ich hatte dann
Vertrauen in den Arzt,
dass er das irgendwie hinkriegt.
Das Beste ...
... war am Schluss, also ...
... als sie wieder heimkam.
Das war wirklich schön.
Mhm.
* Sie sprechen romanisch. *
Im Inselspital ist Vanessa Banz
unterwegs zum nächsten Patienten.
Es geht um
ein erstes Aufklärungsgespräch.
Guten Morgen, Herr Hodel. Banz mein
Name. - Guten Morgen, freut mich.
So, haben Sie es hierher geschafft?
- Ja.
Sehr gut. Wie geht es Ihnen?
Ich bin zufrieden.
Ich habe keine Schmerzen. Tipptopp.
Gut.
Also:
Die Idee des heutigen Gesprächs ist,
dass Sie mich besser kennenlernen
und ich Sie.
Und ich Ihnen ein wenig erzählen
kann, was Transplantation bedeutet.
Jürg Hodel ist 68.
Nach der Pensionierung tauchte beim
früheren SBB-Arbeiter Leberkrebs auf.
Ein Tumor wurde kürzlich erfolgreich
entfernt. Jetzt fühlt er sich gut.
Sie sind eigentlich ein
idealer Transplantationskandidat:
Sie kommen
und sind noch nicht schwerstkrank.
Mhm.
Die Durchschnittswartezeit,
aber das ist nur
der mathematische Durchschnitt,
ist ungefähr ein Jahr.
Mhm. - Okay?
Dieses Jahr muss man überbrücken.
Das ist eine lange Zeit.
Und warten heisst nicht,
Sie sitzen auf dem Sofa und warten.
Ja.
Ab dem Moment, in dem Sie
aktiv auf der Warteliste sind,
könnte theoretisch am gleichen Abend
ein Anruf kommen. Okay?
Und dann gleich einrücken.
- Genau.
Ich sage immer: Die Wahrschein-
lichkeit ist sehr, sehr, sehr klein.
Für ein erstes Aufklärungsgespräch
nimmt sich Vanessa Banz 45 Min. Zeit.
Jeder Patient soll genau wissen,
was auf ihn zukommt,
und die Risiken kennen.
Eine Leber, die von Anfang an
gar nicht funktioniert,
oder eine Verstopfung der Gefässe,
die dazu führt,
dass ein Organ nicht mehr arbeitet,
ist selten.
Selten heisst: 5 %. Weniger.
Aber es kommt nicht gar nie vor -
ab und zu kommt es vor.
Aber dass man dann nicht
rechtzeitig ein neues Organ hat,
das ist wirklich sehr, sehr selten.
Jetzt ... Welche Fragen haben Sie?
Oder Unklarheiten.
Eine Unklarheit ist: Ich habe ...
Dr. Stickel hat mir ja gesagt,
es könne bis zu fünf Jahre gehen,
wenn sich nichts ...
Wenn nichts streut,
oder wie man das nennt.
Ja. Ich meine jetzt,
mit der alten Leber.
Ja.
Dann ... Dann wäre das ja super.
Ich rechne jetzt einfach mit dem.
- Nein.
Es ist so: Wenn man sich
entscheidet für die Transplantation,
klärt man Sie nicht ab
und wartet, bis es zurückkommt.
Mhm.
- Das ist falsch.
Weil wir nicht abschätzen können,
wann und wie es zurückkommt.
Ja.
Zu gern hätte Jürg Hodel
die Operation aufgeschoben.
Ich möchte noch
Ihren Bauch anschauen.
Sie wollen ...
- Den Bauch schnell untersuchen.
Gut, das reicht schon. Gut.
Dort ist es ... - Dort, ja.
Das ist die Leber, die man spürt.
Das macht einen schon etwas ...
Es gibt einem schon zu denken.
Ja.
Da hat man etwas und ...
Da erschrickt man fast ein wenig,
welche Auswirkungen
das alles haben kann.
Also.
- Also. Auf Wiedersehen.
Alles Gute. Wir sehen uns bald.
- Ja, gut.
Aber: Jürg Hodel
sagt Ja zur Transplantation.
Bald wird er aktiv
auf die Warteliste kommen.
Universitätsspital Genf.
Es geht gegen Mitternacht.
Spät am Abend wurde Mireya
aufgeboten zur Transplantation.
* Unruhige Klänge *
Ihr Vater reist im Auto an.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich Mireya noch sehe
oder ob sie schon
im Operationssaal ist.
Und dann die Warterei.
Das wird eine ziemlich krasse Zeit.
Sie wird wahrscheinlich
erst um 11 Uhr transplantiert.
Ja.
Jetzt machen sie eine Blutentnahme.
Die Voruntersuchungen
werden Stunden dauern.
* Die Mutter seufzt. *
Hast du Stress?
- Nein.
Hast du gehört? Du wirst
erst etwa um 11 Uhr operiert.
Hm? Ja?
- Hm.
Ich habe nicht so Lust
auf die Transplantation.
Ich habe keine Lust,
das wieder zu erleben.
Eine Transplantation
hat Mireya noch nie erlebt.
Aber die Erinnerung
an frühere Spitalaufenthalte
sind ein Albtraum für sie.
Inzwischen
ist auch Martin Rast eingetroffen,
im Gepäck ein Plüschtier.
Hauptsache,
sie hat etwas, das sie kennt.
Papi!
Hoi!
Hallo.
- Hallo.
Guten Morgen.
- Guten Morgen, wie geht's?
Noch gut.
Martin Rast ist froh, bei den
Vorbereitungen dabei sein zu können.
Wie heisst er jetzt?
- (Mireya) Bello. - Aha.
3 oder ... Halb 4.
Ohje.
- Halb 4, ja.
* Der Vater gähnt laut. *
(Ärztin) So, ich muss mal in deine
Ohren ... - ...schauen. - Genau.
Untersuchungen,
Blutentnahme, Röntgen.
Mireyas Gesundheitszustand
wird minutiös überprüft.
Aah.
- Okay, kannst du so machen?
- Ist nicht rot, oder?
- Nein. Gar nichts.
Ich habe gestern geschaut,
es war nichts rot.
Noch ist an Schlaf nicht zu denken.
Obwohl sie
die Transplantation herbeisehnten,
steigt bei den Eltern die Angst.
(Ärztin) Das?
- Nein.
Jetzt kannst du einfach liegen.
Okay.
(Vater) Ist das Smartieswasser,
oder was?
Mireya müsste verschiedene
Medikamente zu sich nehmen.
Wie ein Bonbon.
- (Riecht) Mh!
Nein.
Das riecht wie Hustensirup.
* Der Vater lacht. *
Das denkst du nur.
Wirklich!
- Das ist nicht Hustensirup.
Ohne geht es nicht, Mireya.
Muss ich Wasser holen zum Spülen?
- Mireya.
Machst du es selber
oder soll ich?
Besser, ich mache es.
- Nein.
Also, lass sie.
Das ist genau wie Medikamente.
Genau dasselbe.
Früher hast du auch immer Theater
gemacht wegen der Medikamente,
und dann ging es.
Der kleinen Patientin
wird alles zu viel.
Medikamente sind schrecklich für sie,
schon früher hatte sie Mühe damit.
Die Minuten werden zu Stunden.
Ich will gar nicht wissen,
was da drin ist.
Das ist wie ein Gel, das deine
Röhre beschützt und deinen Bauch.
Wie ein kleiner Film.
Denk doch an Rocco.
Der wartet auf dich.
Na?
Bist du stark? Ich glaube auch.
(Flüsternd) Sie werden verlangt.
Sie fragt, ob nicht Sie mit ihr
die Medikamente nehmen könnten.
Wir haben ihr gesagt, das sei
die letzte Chance, sonst ... Ja.
* Die Eltern unterhalten sich
leise im Hintergrund. *
* Leise, sanfte Klänge *
Stress nicht, sonst verkrampft ...
- Hat sie's genommen?
Nein, aber sie verkrampft noch mehr.
- Aber hat sie's genommen?
Du musst nicht
immer nur mit der Peitsche.
* Mireya beklagt sich. *
Runterschlucken!
- Runterschlucken!
He, schlucken! Mit dem Wasser?
(Ärztin) Sie nimmt Wasser. Ja.
So, super.
- (Vater) Willst du noch mehr?
Es wird eine turbulente
und kurze Nacht
vor dem grossen Eingriff.
* Sanfte, perlende Klänge *
Familie Laurent
bricht auf in ihr Maiensäss.
Das Thema Organspende beschäftigte
Anita Laurent schon in jungen Jahren.
Mit 14 besorgte sie sich
einen Organspendeausweis.
* Sie sprechen romanisch. *
Ich hatte einfach das Gefühl ...
Vielleicht
habe ich es irgendwo gelesen.
Ich hatte ganz stark das Gefühl,
dass ich das will.
Das war damals nicht so einfach.
Man konnte nicht einfach
irgendwo einen nehmen, wie heute.
Die Verteilung der Organe ist
im Transplantationsgesetz geregelt.
Die medizinische Dringlichkeit
hat erste Priorität.
D.h.: Ein älterer Mann
hat die gleichen Chancen
wie eine jüngere Frau
mit drei Kindern.
Für mich war z.T. auch schwierig,
wenn ich überlegte:
"Meine Frau ist gesund,
hat eigentlich gesund gelebt."
Hat nie geraucht,
nie Alkohol getrunken,
gesund gegessen.
Ist die Mama von drei Kindern.
Und kriegt keine Leber.
Und einer, der ...
Nichts gegen Alkoholiker,
aber der hätte vor ihr
eine Leber gekriegt.
Und das ist in Ordnung so,
denn sie müssen anhand von
medizinischen Werten entscheiden,
von Blutwerten, Blutbild,
und nicht von Sympathien
oder von Emotionen.
Das kann es nicht sein.
Denn sonst ...
Sonst kann es nicht funktionieren.
Tatsächlich
errechnet ein Algorithmus,
wer als Empfänger
an erster Stelle kommt.
Nach der Dringlichkeit geht es
auch um den medizinischen Nutzen -
zum wem passt ein Organ am besten,
wer profitiert am meisten?
* Sanfte, perlende Klänge *
Für Anita Laurent
war die Organspende lebensrettend.
Die Erlebnisse rund um die zweite
Transplantation sind noch präsent.
In dem Moment, in dem ich
von zu Hause nach Zürich ging,
wusste ich:
"Ich bin jetzt fröhlich und
freue mich, ich habe so viel Glück."
Und für jemand anderes
ist es gerade ...
Es liegt gerade jemand im Sterben.
Das ist das Schwierige.
Das war sehr schwierig.
Ja.
Ich spürte irgendwie, dass
diese Person mir das gern gab. Ja.
Ich glaube, darum geht es so gut,
darum passt es so gut.
Es ist eine gute Energie.
Waren Sie nie neugierig, von wem ...
- Doch, doch. Jeden Tag.
Mhm.
Jeden Tag denke ich:
"Wie war wohl diese Person?"
oder ... Ja.
Ich hätte sie gern kennengelernt.
Im richtigen Leben
geht es halt nicht,
aber ich spreche oft mit der Person.
Fast jeden Tag.
Die Empfänger dürfen die
Spenderfamilie nicht kennenlernen.
Es gilt das Prinzip der Anonymität.
Man hat gewisse Ängste,
dass eine Abhängigkeit entsteht,
oder sogar Druck oder Forderungen.
Das will man auch verhindern.
Denn eine Organspende ist ein
Geschenk. Und das soll so bleiben.
Es gibt die Möglichkeit,
anonym Briefe auszutauschen.
Leider wird das
viel zu wenig genutzt.
Viele Empfänger haben das Gefühl,
sie könnten in einem Brief
nicht zum Ausdruck bringen,
was dieses Geschenk bedeutet,
für sie, ihr Umfeld, ihr Leben.
* Er spricht romanisch. *
Anita Laurent
möchte irgendwann wieder
in ihren Beruf als Kindergärtnerin
zurückkehren.
Es gibt nichts, von dem wir denken,
wir hätten's anders machen sollen.
Wir hatten auch nicht die Wahl,
etwas anders zu machen. - Ja.
Wir mussten den Ärzten vertrauen.
100 %.
Wir mussten Entscheidungen treffen -
Operation Ja oder Nein,
ein paar Mal.
Aber wenn man leben will, muss
man sich für ein Ja entscheiden,
sonst ist es nachher zu spät.
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Am Unispital Genf
rückt Mireyas Operationstermin näher.
Die Co-Leiterin des Leberzentrums,
Barbara Wildhaber,
kommt zur letzten Visite.
- Schau, wer kommt. Hoher Besuch.
Hoi, Mäuschen. Hoi!
Bist du auch gekommen?
* Der Vater lacht. *
Hoi.
- Hoi.
Bist du etwas durcheinander?
- Mhm.
Ich verstehe dich. Wie geht es dir
von 0 bis 10? - Gut.
0 bis 10?
- 10.
10! 10 von 10?
Oho, so gut! Haben Sie's gehört?
(Beide) Ja.
- 10 von 10.
Bald kommst du in den Ops.
Dann geht das grosse Abenteuer los.
Du weisst, was Ops heisst,
nicht wahr?
Du hast schon etwas Angst, nicht?
Ich verstehe dich.
Aber das müssen wir ja nicht sagen.
- Mhm.
Habe ich danach
wieder Schläuche am Bein, hier?
Normalerweise nicht.
Am Bein hast du nichts.
Du hast sicher eins am Hals.
Das kennst du ja. Aber ein kleines.
Kein grosses.
- Und am ersten Tag im Mund?
Genau. Das kennst du ja,
es ist für den Magen.
Am nächsten Tag nicht mehr?
- Zwei, drei Tage.
Aber am ersten Tag
schläfst du ohnehin.
Ich habe es
Mami und Papi gesagt:
vielleicht ist es
viel weniger schlimm als ihr denkt.
Nicht aufziehen da!
Du hast schon viel Schlimmes erlebt
und denkst, es werde wieder so.
Wird's wahrscheinlich nicht.
Hast du noch Fragen?
Nein.
- Perfekt. Dann würden wir gehen?
Da kriegen Sie gleich Herzklopfen,
nicht wahr?
Ja, immer mehr, immer mehr.
Jetzt gehen sie mit ihr
in den Ops, dann etwas trinken,
und v.a. schlafen. Ich weiss,
Sie schlafen nicht, aber tun Sie so.
Okay?
- Vielleicht laufen wir etwas rum.
* Helle, eindringliche Klänge *
Mir steigen auch
die Tränen in die Augen.
Denn die Eltern sind so geladen
nach allem, was die erlebt haben.
Sie haben schon zweimal
ihre Tochter praktisch verloren.
Jetzt geben sie sie ab
und wissen nicht, was passiert.
Ich weiss, es ist kontrolliert.
Aber sie wissen das ja nicht.
Sie haben Todesangst
um ihre Tochter,
weil sie von uns gehört haben:
Es ist ein Riesending.
Darum konnte ich nicht mit. Sonst
wären mir auch die Tränen gekommen.
* Helle, eindringliche Klänge *
Tschüss, Mireya.
Mach's gut.
Sie merkt nichts mehr. Ciao!
Mach's gut, gell?
Ist gut? Alles gut bei dir?
Puh.
* Emotionale, aufgewühlte Klänge *
Genf ist das einzige Trans-
plantationszentrum in der Schweiz,
das die Leber
bei Kindern transplantieren darf.
Routine ist dieser Eingriff aber nie.
Es berührt uns tief,
weil es um Leben und Tod geht.
Die Freude an und für sich, dass wir
ein Organ für Mireya haben, ist ...
... sehr emotional geprägt durch die
Trauer, dass jemand gestorben ist.
Noch ist die Spenderleber für Mireya
nicht eingetroffen.
Der Zeitplan ist genau kalkuliert.
Allein die Entnahme der kranken Leber
wird Stunden in Anspruch nehmen.
Barbara Wildhaber ruft zum Time-out,
bei dem routinemässig
die Identität des Patienten
und die Art des Eingriffs
geprüft werden.
Alors, time-out. Name?
- Mireya Rast.
Operationsstelle?
- Bauch.
Art des Eingriffs?
- Wechsel der Leber.
Luigi wird die Leber abholen,
frisch. Wir machen nichts damit.
Aber sie ist sehr wertvoll.
Die ganze Welt
interessiert sich dafür.
* Sie spricht französisch. *
Mireyas Leber
soll genau untersucht werden,
um ihrer noch wenig erforschten
Genkrankheit auf die Spur zu kommen.
Die Transplantation kann beginnen.
* Regelmässiges Piepen *
Je peux?
Je peux.
In der nächsten Sendung:
Die lange Operation wird für Katja
und Martin Rast zur Zerreissprobe.
Wie geht's?
Bruno Romang
wartet auf ein Spenderherz.
Was ich habe, weiss er.
Dass ich ein anderes Herz bekomme.
Das war am Anfang
etwas hart für ihn.
Wiedersehen
mit dem Patienten Rene Cart.
Ca va?
- Guten Morgen. Viel besser.
Er hat nach der Transplantation
eine schwere Zeit erlebt.
Und: Wie sieht eine Transplantation
auf Seite des Organspenders aus?
In der nächsten Folge von
"Ich will leben!".